so next up we have so in this talk I'll
be talking about how we can design
better algorithms for different
average-case models of graph
partitioning and how we can design
algorithms for a related problem of
learning different roll the stick models
for clustering or graph partitioning and
all of this work is joint work with
Konstantin McCurry Shiv and Yuri
Macarius so let me start out by fixing
my pointer let me start out by defining
the class of graph partitioning problems
just so that we are all on the same page
so in graph partitioning you are given a
graph okay but in different vertices and
the goal is to divide the graph into a
bunch of disjoint clusters okay subject
to some constraints which are problem
specific for instance in balance cut you
are given this graph and the goal is to
split the graph into two equal parts or
to roughly equal parts so that you
minimize the number of edges that go
between these two parts okay also
balanced gave a partitioning you want to
split the graph into K roughly equal
pieces so that you minimize the number
of edges that go between the different
clusters and so on so depending on
different constraints you get different
problems but this is a very general
broad class of problems called graph
partitioning and that'll be the focus of
this talk so graph partitioning problems
are typically np-hard to solve and
they've been a central area of study in
approximation algorithms and you know so
because you are np-hard to solve
typically we design good approximation
algorithms for these problems so here
you want to design a polynomial time
algorithm which is always within with
which outputs a solution which is always
within a factor an alpha factor ideally
it's a constant you want it to be as
small as possible of the optimal
solution for that instance
okay so that's the approximation ratio
and this is what we want this is this
measures the performance of the
algorithm and do a lot of really seminal
works we have a poly logarithmic in N n
is the number of vertices in the graph
you have poly logarithmic approximations
for a lot of this lot of these problems
in this class so on the other set on the
other hand from a hardness perspective
we have evidence to believe based on the
unique games conjecture or strengthening
of it like the small sieve expansion
conjecture that constant factor
approximation for all these problems are
unlikely okay so so just to summarize
from a worst-case standpoint only poly
logarithmic approximation algorithms are
known for a lot of these problems and
constant factor approximation czar
unlikely and so the obvious question I
mean given this workshop is can we do
better from an average case standpoint
so I mean again with average case
analysis we need a probability
distribution over all instances and if
you want a better average case
approximation ratio the goal is to find
an algorithm which will always output I
mean which will output for any given
instance from this distribution you
measure the cost of the solution output
by our algorithm divided by the cost of
the optimal solution and you want this
to be less than alpha with high
probability okay so this kind of
guarantee typically also implies a good
expected approximation ratio because you
can always get a n factor approximation
for a lot of these problems okay and the
main challenge in average case analysis
is to full so on the one hand you want
your average case distribution to be
rich enough to capture instances that
come up in practice on the other I mean
on the other hand you want much better
guarantees then you can get in the worst
case okay so this I mean there's a
trade-off between these two okay so
before we go into different average case
models so a lot of the models that we
look at are basically inspired from
machine learning and here are some
examples that I mean you might encounter
so on the left is a
collaboration network where you have a
bunch of researchers in order I mean by
vertices and edges if these two reaches
I mean two researchers have collaborated
on a paper together on the right there's
a protein protein interaction graph and
in all these kinds of graphs you see
that there are these nice clusters and
there are many more edges inside
clusters and fewer edges between
clusters and this is typically what you
want your average case models to capture
okay so and your average case
distribution will typically generate
such instances with many edges inside
clusters and fewer edges between
clusters okay and in all these problems
you can look for two different kinds of
objectives or two different kinds of
goals and the first one is support
approximating the objective so for
instance if you are looking at a problem
like balance cut where you want to split
the graph into two pieces
now you minimize the number of edges
that go between them here you are trying
to find a partition so you're given a
graph that is generated from this
distribution and let's say that that is
this planted cut at an optimal cut so we
are going to denote it by H okay and the
goal here is to output a balanced
partition whose cost is small compared
to the cost of the planted cut okay so
here the goal is to approximate the
objective that is to find a to find a
solution of small cost and the quality
of the algorithm is measured by
comparing the cost of your solution to
the cost of the planted cut so if you
have no information about the instance
then the best you can hope for is I mean
a square root login or a login
approximation in the worst case but if
your distribution is nice hopefully you
can get a much better I mean performance
with respect to the plant except
hopefully a constant factor so that's
the first goal now another goal that you
can ask for is comes from a machine
learning standpoint a very typical
paradigm and unsupervised learning is to
assume that the data that's given to you
comes from a very nice distribution that
is that is appropriate for that task at
hand so for instance
given points in space you may assume
that your data is generated from a
Gaussian mixture model or for graph
partitioning so when you have
communities in networks for instance you
assume that the graph is generated by a
nice probabilistic model okay and in
this case the goal here is to actually
learn the model so it's not necessarily
to find a partition of small cost here
the goal is to learn the individual
communities and to learn the generator
model that produced the cost okay with
high probability so these are two
different goals so the first goal is
something that we are used to in the
approximation algorithms community of
the theory community the second goal is
more common in machine learning but
while these are different goals they are
very related because typically the the
objective that you care about for
instance the balance cut objective
corresponds to the maximum likelihood
estimator for the probabilistic model at
hand okay but this may not always be
true it depends on the average case
model but typically if you can get a
good approximation for the objective it
also translates to recovering the
community if the distribution has a nice
structure ok so throw out the stock will
be looking at both these goals and I'll
talk about different average case models
and whether we can find good
approximations to the objective and
whether we can learn the model and
recover the communities
any questions so far so let's start out
with a very simple average case model
for graph partitioning so this is called
the stochastic block model so for
balance cut you have these two pieces of
equal size let's say that they are of
size n each and this this is the hidden
partition that's not given to you okay
and the edges in the graph has been
generated as follows with some
probability Q which I will denote as B
over N we will see why it's B over n
little bit with some probability Q there
is an edge between any two vertices in
different sides of the cut so for any
two given vertices from I mean one from
L and one from uh there's an edge
between them at all
the queue okay and you do this
independently at random for each pair of
vertices from L&R okay similarly with
between any two vertices in the same
side of the cut so in the same cluster L
or R there is an edge between them
Authority P which is a over N okay so
and it's chosen to be larger than B so
you will have many more edges inside the
clusters in between the clusters so
because of this choice of parameters the
average degree of a vertex on the left
okay so within its own cluster is going
to be a and the average number of edges
that go across the cluster is going to
be B okay so just to ensure that we're
all on the same page okay and this kind
of a model will be is called a
stochastic block model and it's just
represented as I mean using this
notation it just means there are n
vertices in each of these clusters there
are two clusters the average degree
inside the inside the clusters is a and
between the clusters is B and then you
can generalize this and here the goal is
to recover for instance in I mean if you
look at the second goal here the goal is
to recover the two communities L or not
and if you find the two communities you
can also figure out the parameters of HQ
you can also generalize this to K in a
partitioning where there are K
communities of equal size n so the total
number of vertices is n times K so it's
a very symmetric setting and again edges
inside these clusters are present with
probability P which is a over N and it
just across clusters are present with
already Q which is B over N and a is
greater than B and so if the expected
degree of a vertex inside his own
cluster and B is the expected degree of
a vertex to certain other cluster okay
so if you fix two clusters B if the
average degree from a vertex to a
certain other cluster so this is a
setting okay and here remember every
edge is toes in every edge choice is
chosen independently at random
the stochastic block model and there's a
lot of work on stochastic block model
across different communities and
statistics in theoretical computer
science I mean and so on and it has also
been generalized to handle different
edge probabilities inside clusters and
between clusters or different expected
degrees and so on there's a lot of work
on stochastic block models and broadly
speaking these different algorithmic
results that are known fall under three
categories okay so the first what are
known as exact recovery results so here
the goal is to recover the communities
exactly all the community memberships
with high probability for each of the
vertices in partial recovery you care
about classifying 90% of the vertices so
one minus Delta fraction of all the
vertices and in weak recovery you mainly
care about just finding a partition that
is better than random okay there's
something better than done okay so these
are the kind of results that I mean
these are the three broad classes of
results that exist and I'll go over a
little bit about each of them okay so so
a lot of the work on stochastic block
c'mere I mean block models is about
recap recovering each of the communities
exactly and starting from the work of
bopanna in 88 and Frank McSherry and so
on so we know that spectral algorithms
okay we just find the top K eigenvectors
and then project onto them and then
cluster based on the top here again
vectors they can actually find the two
communities as long as says enough
separation between the Rigbys okay so
here so this square root of a plus P
corresponds to the standard deviation
when you look at the difference between
the number of edges inside its own
community and across I mean to a
different community and as long as a
minus B is root square root login times
the standard deviation then with high
probability you can recover all the
communities I mean all the vertices in
different communities
okay and this can be extended to general
okay where I mean you get essentially
the same kind of result and this term
here is because the standard deviation
now this square root of a plus K minus
one times B and where C is some
appropriately chosen absolute universal
constant and now we have a very good
understanding of what exactly this
constant is so so there's a sharp
characterization so if it is larger than
this particular constant times the
standard deviation you can recover
exactly with high probability otherwise
its information theoretically hard to
recover all the community memberships so
this is about exact recovery but in all
these cases I mean for for these
conditions to hold you need that the
average degree should be at least
logarithmic in it and I mean if it is
less than logarithmic and then you may
not even have connectivity in the graph
so you can't hope to recover all the
communities exactly as long as it's at
least log in these this will start
kicking but what about the sparse regime
because I mean a lot of social network
graph for instance sparse and here I
mean this is result by I mean koja
glance who who showed that you can
actually even though the graph may not
be connected in this pass regime you can
still find a polynomial time algorithm
that finds the minimum balance cut as
long as that is sufficient difference
between the inside cluster degree and
the inter cluster degree and of course
you can't hope to recover the
memberships exactly but in the series of
books they were able to show that you
can recover the community memberships up
to Delta fraction being errors as long
as there is this much difference in the
degrees okay the inside cluster degrees
in the between cluster degrees you don't
need to focus that much on the exact
relationship between a B and so on it's
just to give a sense of the kind of
results that I mean the kind of
conditions that you need about these
degrees okay so these are partial
recovery results so here
this give was smooth kind of a guarantee
because if you substitute Delta being
one over n you recover the exact
recovery guarantees and so and the last
line of work is about peak recovery but
the goal is to basically try to output
some partition which has non-trivial
correlation with the planted partition
so for K being two you just want the
partition to have more than half
correlation with the non I mean with the
planted partition and here do these
amazing results by Mosul Neiman and sly
and Masoli a they sort this sharp face
transition that occurs so as long as a
minus B divided by the standard
deviation is larger than one then they
give a polynomial time algorithm that
can output this this partition with
non-trivial correlation and if it is
less than 1 then it is information
theoretically impossible to do so okay
so these are various results that are
there about stochastic block models I
only focused on symmetric stochastic
block models but a lot of these results
also I mean not the shop
characterization but they also exist for
various generalizations of stochastic
block on ok so in this the focus of this
talk will be about partial recovery we
won't be looking at exactly covering ok
so well I mean there's a lot of this
nice work on various stochastic block
models is of course a fair criticism
from I mean an applied community and the
criticism is that you never expect data
to be generated exactly according to a
given model ok there's always noise and
so there may be different kinds of noise
for instance there may be outliers or
corruptions in these edges or you know
the given model is not really a good fit
so you're not general I mean you're not
given a graph that is generated exactly
according to a stochastic block model
but it comes from some other
probabilistic model that's close to a
stochastic block more so there's just
some model in the specification
okay and you want your algorithms to be
robust to this kind of noise and I think
it's a I mean it's something I think
it's a very important criteria in
picking a good learning algorithm you
want your learning algorithm to be
robust to nice yes so has anybody done
an empirical study of SBM type models
because they make a specific prediction
right where the edges will be okay
predictive yeah so I have people done
that study and what they find is them at
all reasonable model for social yes yeah
I don't know actually
so in the sense that I think people
agree that it's not a good model for
social network graphs because you know
in social network graphs you see things
like yeah lot of triangles large cliques
and so on dense sub-graphs and so on so
an SPM is not a good model for these but
perhaps in other settings it is a
reasonable model like biological
networks or just surprising that they've
been around for 20 30 40 years and
nobody's done this very well yeah I mean
the must be but I don't know about
Oklahoma City
so and you could ask okay how robust are
usual approaches for instance if you
look at spectral clustering which tries
to find which finds the top K
eigenvectors of your graph the adjacency
matrix of your craft projects and
clusters them then these kind of
spectral methods are very brittle to
noise because you can just corrupt a few
edges or a few entries in your matrix
and your spectrum can go haywire okay so
in this sense spectral methods are not
very robust and so are methods like
counting paths and random walks and so
on which are often used to get these
kind of guarantees for stochastic plot
models okay on the other hand in the
statistics community of maximum
likelihood estimators are typically used
for learning various tralala stick
models and they have some good
robustness properties because typically
they find the best fit Prada stick model
measured in KL divergence even if
there's modeling error but however the
problem with maximum likelihood
estimation is that it's typically
np-hard for instance for Rhonda stick
models it just corresponds to finding
the minimum balance cut so you want
algorithms which are polynomial time
algorithms which are also robust to
various kinds of noise and modeling
errors okay and finally I mean just as
sandy was mentioning stochastic block
models so these kind of simple random
models are not very do not have the kind
of properties that real-world graphs do
because they assume a lot of
independence and real world graphs for
instance have heavy tail degree
distributions or then sub graphs large
fleex and so on and these are not
properties that are exhibited by the
stochastic block model simple random
graphs
additionally regress okay and so you
want more general average case models
that can capture these kind of
real-world graph properties you want to
assume as little as possible about your
average case model and still show good
probable guarantees so so I'll do this
in this talking I mean along I mean in
two different ways so first I'll talk
about different average case models like
models that started with this work by
Feige and Killian and we'll talk about
how you can incorporate different kinds
of adversarial choices into your model
and how you can make them more and more
general okay so here the focus will
mainly be an approximating the objective
and in the second part of the talk I'll
talk about how you can handle different
kinds of modeling error you can assume
that your graph is drawn from a
stochastic block model but some kind of
bits noise so you have various kinds of
modeling error and I'll show how you can
recover the communities up to good
accuracy in that case good so so the
first semi random model for graph
partitioning was the one that was
proposed by Feige and Killian so they
came up with this really nice model
where you assume that your graph is
first drawn from a stochastic block
model of the splendored partitioning
model but additionally an adversary can
then come and delete it just between
clusters or add edges inside clusters so
that these kind of changes are only
monotone changes because this deleting
edges inside clusters are adding edges
sorry they're leading edges between
clusters or adding edges inside clusters
only makes your planted solution even
better okay so this is called a monitor
an adversary and the question is whether
you know these algorithms for learning
stochastic block models still work in
the presence of a monotone adversary
okay and unfortunately we I mean we
don't know that
spectral algorithms do but Feige and
Kellyanne showed that you can use STPs
semi-definite programs to make these
spectral algorithms robust if they
showed that under essentially the same
kind of conditions about the difference
between the inside cluster degree in
between cluster degree perhaps with the
slightly worse constant
I mean SV piece will actually recover
the community memberships so it does
both the job of finding the optimal
solution and learning the community
memberships so this is about monotone
adversaries and this has been extended
to K way partitioning with similar
guarantees
well okay and all these algorithms use
convex relaxations like semi definite
programs so you could ask ok so monotone
adversaries only seem to make your life
easier because you're planted solution
only becomes better but so is there a
formal way in which this is true a
formal sense in which it's true and in a
surprising result by Moitra
theory in vain they showed that I mean
in some settings having monotone
adversities actually make your heart
I mean life harder the sense that you
have these phase transitions for weak
recovery for a stochastic block model
they showed that when you have a
monotone adversary you can construct a
monotone adversary such that the
threshold under which weak recovery is
possible becomes worse yes so while
intuitively it seems like monotone
adversity should only help you they
actually show that with monotone
adversaries means there are settings
where it actually becomes worse and
there are lots of interesting open
questions about monotone adversaries I
think one nice question is do we
actually need several different programs
to get algorithms that are robust to
monitor adversaries can simpler
algorithms for expected methods I mean
can you come up with modifications of
counting based approaches that actually
work with monotone adversaries and
however one issue with monotone
adversities that meanwhile you get some
adversarial nature because of these
monotone changes the model still assumes
a lot of independence ok and if you look
at the kind of proofs that are involved
it uses strong properties about the
spectrum of the graph ok and so
essentially each of these edges are
chosen independently at random and you
can't have triangles that go between
different clusters or dense sub-graphs
it go between different clusters and
you'd like your average case models to
be more general enough to capture these
kind of settings
so so so here's another semi random
model which it's a little more general
than monotone adversaries model so we're
here the goal is to capture arbitrary
correlations inside clusters okay so
here there are there is a splendid
partition L&R and you have arbitrary
edges inside the partitions and they
just between the partitions l and r are
random so here you can think of it as
essentially think of a perfect partition
okay so this is L or not so you have
whatever it just you want inside and and
R and nothing between Ln R and then you
have random noise between the clusters
so this is more general than the FICA
Killian model in the sense that you have
arbitrary adjust between okay and you
can show that under this model for
various problems like balance cut or K
way partitioning and so on you can get a
good constant factor approximation so
this is getting closed in objective as
long as the number of edges is at least
as long as the average degree is at
least square root login you can get a
constant factor approximation so this is
about the first goal then you pass what
about the second goal that is learning
the length ground truth partition and
unfortunately because you can have
arbitrary correlations inside the
clusters ground truth recovery is
impossible
okay this because you could just have a
GNP graph inside GNP go up inside and
adjust property BP between okay so and
in this case you can't hope to recover
the underlying partitions and so in
general you can't recover the underlying
I mean the the partitions unless you
have some kind of expansion properties
inside the clusters and so what we can
show is that as long as you have good
expansion properties that is the
expansion inside the clusters I won't
formally define the notion of expansion
we use as long as the expansion inside
the clusters is a constant and small
and expansion of the planet cut you can
also recover the communities up to good
accuracy so you can do partial recovery
what it means might need expansion and
near assumptions so if you don't have I
mean suppose you have a very sparse cut
inside then you can just move the cut to
the other side and you are not actually
losing anything in the cost so you do I
mean yeah so expansion assumptions are
necessary some kind of expansion
assumptions are necessary and yeah
assuming this kind of an expansion
assumption you can recover the
communities so this is nice but however
it's the the graph between the two
clusters is still random okay and we
like to get rid of this so here also so
joint work with makhachev and mechanics
have a proposed this model called the
random permutation invariant at just
model so this is the model so here you
think of this graph as being split into
two parts
okay so then it's just planted partition
L comma odd that's not known to you okay
so you think of it as being split into
this graph inside clusters plus a graph
that is between clusters okay so and
ideally we'd want the edges inside
clusters to be completely arbitrary and
they just between clusters to also be
arbitrary okay but that's not possible
because that would be a worst-case
instance so what we did instead instead
of shioma set the inside cluster edges
are arbitrary and we'll just assume that
the between cluster edges come from any
distribution that is permutation
invariant so what do I mean by this I
just want this graph that comes between
clusters to come from any distribution
that doesn't depend on the identity of
the vertices so one way of generating
such a graph is think of an arbitrary
graph inside the clusters think of an
arbitrary graph between clusters and he
just randomly lead relabeled the
vertices here
okay and just fuse the two glass
together okay so that that's a graph
that's that comes from a permutation
invariant distribution so so what's the
advantage compared to previous models
well it's more general but in some way
of capturing independence between the
inside cluster edges in the between
cluster edges because you'd think that
it just come from multiple I mean edges
in a social network could come from
different kinds of patient shifts maybe
work relationships or sports and so on
and these edges should really be
independent of each other
and this is just a way of capturing this
independence between inside class
syringes in between cluster edges okay
but I mean more concretely this inter
cluster edges could could capture
complex distributions so they could come
from you know your preferential
attachment models or your favorite kind
of an average case model that is just
that doesn't really rely on identities
of you know labels of vertices it's some
kind of a symmetry property okay so you
can have large cliques or dense
sub-graphs and so on between clusters as
well and so what what we can show is
that we can give a constant factor
approximation for graphs that are drawn
from the PI model as long as you have as
long as the average degree is at least
log square n so the way I'd like to
think about it is is that this algorithm
okay so in some sense it says that
minimum balance cut is easy as long as
your graphs come from any average case
model that satisfies this permutation
invariance property some kind of a
symmetry property and so I mean there
are quite a few open questions here so
this is just thing to I mean the first
and I mean potentially multiple things
that you could do so you could ask for
guarantees for K way partitioning and
one thing that we would really like to
do but we don't quite know how to go
about it this recovering the communities
when it comes from some kind of
distribution that is permutation
invariance what kind of property should
be assumed about the average gas
distribution so that you can actually
recover the community suspect so you can
do the second algorithmic code any
questions about this oh thank you yeah
so yes I didn't go into the algorithm at
all
so the algorithm uses semi definite
programming so the algorithm goes by
showing so by using a semi definite
program that's actually the same semi
definite program that's used in the
worst case but it shows some additional
structural properties about the same a
different program so in particular it
says that the semi definite program is
partially integral so all the edge
weights I mean so the edge length so the
semi definite program will define
lengths of edges and it could take
arbitrary values from 0 to 1 what we
will show is that for most of the edges
that go that are in the planted cut the
edge lengths are going to be at least
1/2 or I mean value it will not be as
small as 1 over log in or 1 over pollen
okay so that is what allows us to get
these constant factor guarantees
any other questions orders so yeah
actually that's another thing that we
don't know so for all we know it you
could actually do but you could actually
get this to work for sparse graphs as
well they actually have no reason to
believe that this is necessary I see so
is it kind of related to you know
finding the top K eigenvectors and going
about it yeah okay so I don't quite know
how robust they are but yeah that's
another approach it would be nice to
show guarantees for those kind of
approach this bill so if it's based on
things like matrix completions so I
guess it would fit into the convex
relaxation approach and I think I mean
an SDP is actually going to be stronger
than such a algorithm but you're right
so it's such evidence of probably more
practical and solving nice to show
guarantees for such algorithms this way
ok so the last part of the talk I'll
talk about how you can capture modeling
errors ok so here it was really about
more more general average case models
but I mean now we look at the other
viewpoint of looking at the unsupervised
learning task of learning a
probabilistic model in the presence of
Arabs so here we like to deal with
different kinds of errors so one kind of
error is outliers or corruptions and
another kind of error is model miss
specification and we will capture this
in different ways so how do we capture
outliers or corruptions so we'll assume
that the graph has generated by the
following process so the graph is first
drawn from a stochastic block model as
before and then the adversary has a
budget ok let's say that
em that's the number of edges in this
graph the expected number of edges in
this graph now the adversity is a budget
of epsilon n okay and this adversity can
add or delete edges add whatever it is
he or she wants or delete whatever edges
that have been produced but in total the
budget should be epsilon M okay so it
has a total budget of epsilon m and the
adversary can delete epsilon 2 x m and
can add some a bunch of edges but in
total the number of corruptions that the
adversary makes is at most epsilon m
okay so you can think of this as a
stochastic block model plus constant
fraction of them being arbitrarily
corrupted so this is this is how you'd
capture korat we capture corruptions and
then the second thing is about model
miss specification okay so here this is
related to how a maximum likelihood
estimator finds the best fit model in KL
divergence so we asked okay so what if
the graph didn't come exactly from a
stochastic block model but it came from
any distribution there's close to a
stochastic block model in KL divergence
so I'm not going to go into the exact
definition okay so here's the definition
in case you want it but so we're just
going to assume then it comes from any
distribution cube that is close to a
stochastic block model in KL divergence
up to ETA times M think of it as being a
small constant like point naught 1 okay
so this way of measuring modeling error
through KL divergence it also captures
adversarial edge additions but not quite
deletions so they're kind of
incomparable ok but this is one way by
which so here now there just can be very
dependent whereas in a stochastic block
model they are each a choice is
independent okay so what we can show is
that you can get robust learning
guarantees of this form your algorithm
can learn a stochastic block model even
if the even if a constant fraction of
the edges are arbitrarily corrupted and
if there is scale divergence model
misfit
application of ETA times where M that
ETA is also a small constant okay so you
can you can tolerate outlier edges
constant fraction of them being outlier
edges a constant fraction sorry ETA
times M distance and KL divergence and
any amount of monotone errors in the
fire carrion form and what we can show
us it you can recover the community is
up to ETA accuracy where either has this
form I mean I'm not going to go into
exactly what this form is but the thing
that I'd like to point out is that if
there is no noise this is the this is
the dependence of the recovery
guarantees with respect to a and B and
these are the guarantees that you would
also expect in the no noise setting so
it's very comparable to how much you can
recover even in the no noise setting yes
give us a sense for how much deviation
this killed awareness allows like what
kinds of so for instance it does allow
arbitrary edge additions up to eat I
mean the same eater times M so but it's
also captured by outlier errors but you
can also do things like modify each edge
probability a little bit but you can
also modify them in a dependent fashion
so yeah so KL divergence captures both
kinds of errors in that sense so you can
think of all the errors as being focused
on a few edges or it could also smear
the changes across the graph yeah so
that's yeah so that's one nice thing
about kailyn's okay so you can tolerate
you can do partial recovery even when
you up to some constant fraction of them
being modeling errors and there is some
sense in which this is optimal so if you
look at the two terms that come about
one of them comes from a no noise term
and so that's that kind of a dependence
is necessary even if there is no noise
this is necessary even if there's no
noise and this is the noise term and
there is some sense in which at least
for two communities this
dependence is necessary okay up to
constant factors but I'm not going to
the specifics so I must say that there
is this there's also related work on how
you can come up with algorithms that are
robust to noise so this is very nice
work by Kumar and Canon who showed that
you can do you can learn various politic
models like Gaussian mixtures or blended
partitioning models when the noise is
structured in some way in the spectral
norm of certain noise matrix has some
nice properties and then there's also
worked by chi and leaf which who try to
capture vertex out lights okay but any
outliers are more general than vertex
outliers so so in some sense other cells
subsume these results by kindly so in
the next one or two minutes let me try
to give you a overview of the algorithm
for justice learning stochastic block
models in the presence of noise so here
it also both by using a semi definite
program so you write down a semi
definite program for balanced care
partitioning and then what you do if you
treat these SDP vectors I mean you look
at these STP vectors
okay the vector is given by the semi
definite program and then you just apply
a simple greedy clustering algorithm all
these vectors
you said actually describe the greedy
clustering algorithm I think it's fairly
intuitive so let me describe it now so
before we go there this is the semi
definite programming relaxation so you
don't need to look at what exactly the
semi definite program is it just assigns
unit vectors to every vertex in your
graph and then it allows you to define
the concept of distance between vertices
okay so the distance between vertices
exactly corresponds to the squared
Euclidean distance between the
corresponding vectors so there's not
really not really a distance because we
don't impose triangle inequalities but
you can think of them as a distance and
intuitively you you think that the
vectors that are in the same cluster
should be close to each other so what we
do is we we measure there are two
quantities that come that are very
useful you can look at the average inter
cluster distance
that is the average over all pairs of
vertices from the same cluster of the
distance between them and the average
inter cluster distance and what we are
able to show is that for a stochastic
block model the average interact lustre
distance is very small and the average
inter cluster distance is very large is
very close to 1 and this is true even if
you have various kinds of modeling
errors ok so now suppose given that we
have the structural property the
algorithm the algorithm becomes fairly
simple what you do is you just take this
STP solution and you apply a BD
clustering algorithm so what you do is
you just look at all the active vertices
that are there ok and you just look at
balls of size of a fixed radius and you
pick the heaviest ball that exists so
you look at balls of radius let's say
0.1 look at how many vertices are inside
these balls and then pick the heaviest
ball that you can find and then remove
this whole ball and then trick us so
it's just a greedy clustering algorithm
on the STP vectors and be sure that this
can recover the community memberships up
to good accuracy and this is based on
showing some structural conditions about
the STP
let me not go into this ok so let me
just conclude by thing that you know so
in the stock we looked at different
average case models for graph
partitioning there are more general than
stochastic block models and that may
allow us to capture real world graph
graphs instances and we also looked at
algorithms for learning probabilistic
models for graph partitioning in the
presence of various kinds of errors like
corruptions or outliers model Mis
specification and it'll be nice to come
up with you know these kind of
guarantees for graphs partitioning or
other such problems under other natural
properties about the average case model
so one way I like to think about the PI
model is to say that you get good
guarantees as long as your average case
model satisfies it's not focused on a
particular average case model it works
for any average case model that
satisfies this symmetry property of
permutation invariance will be nice to
say that you know you can
I mean you identify other natural
properties of average-case distributions
that are love you to get much better
guarantees and it also be nice to get
this kind of robust learning guarantees
for various probabilistic models yeah
for yeah other probably stick models for
graph clustering and so on model right
where the people on the Left all their
friends but their dependents in their
choices for the different people are
independent that but different people
choose ha I see I see now in the
identical case your thing includes that
but then non identical what is identical
here the same distribution oh yes that's
right
oh that's a nice thing yeah I haven't
thought about it yeah no I have not
thought about it but that's a very nice
property that yeah we should think about
yeah I haven't quite thought about that
any other questions thank you so you
just do that like within a factor of
five of each other so the sizes of the
cluster yeah so right so I only
presented results when all the clusters
have equal size so these algorithms are
fairly robust to those things too but I
don't quite know how badly degrades with
the skewness of the cluster sizes yeah
we didn't quite work that out